This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in the 1980s, when Louis Smuts was growing up in Johannesburg, South Africa, his family couldn't go outside together without breaking the law. My father would never walk next to my mother. My mother would always walk behind him wherever they went. Louis was too young to understand why his parents couldn't be seen together in Johannesburg, or as everyone calls it, Joe Burke. Louis just saw a world that treated them differently.
这里是 99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。上世纪80年代，当路易斯·斯穆茨在南非约翰内斯堡长大时，他的家人甚至不能一起走在街上，否则就是违法。我父亲绝不会挨着我母亲走。无论去哪儿，我母亲总是走在他身后。路易斯当时太小，无法理解为什么他的父母不能一起出现在约翰内斯堡——或者正如大家所叫的，约堡。路易斯只看到一个以不同方式对待他们的世界。
You know, if your mother got sick and didn't have a medical age, she'd go to a hospital out of the city. Whereas, when you're dead, you'd go to what is the Joe Burke gene, which was around the corner from where we stayed. Healthcare, like almost everything else in South Africa, was decided by race. Louise's father was white. His mother was colored, a local term, for people of mixed race. They'd gotten married in neighboring swatting land, but back home their marriage was against
你知道的，如果你母亲生病了却没有医疗卡，她得去城外的医院。而当你去世时，你会去约堡的基因（基因其实是当地的殡仪馆/街区名，译为基因/地区），就在我们住处转角。医疗保健和南非的几乎所有事物一样，是由种族决定的。路易斯的父亲是白人。他的母亲是有色人种，这是当地对混血儿的称呼。他们是在邻近的斯瓦蒂土地上结的婚，但在老家，他们的婚姻是违反
the law. When Louise was a kid, only white people could move freely in cities here, live in the nicest neighborhoods, or access the best hospitals, schools, and jobs. This is Dashaan Mudley, he's a South African journalist. Black people, on the other hand, lived in the crowded outskirts, which were far from just about everything you'd want in the city. The country's ruling white minority called this system a partate, which literally translated
法律的。在路易斯小时候，只有白人才能在这里的城市里自由穿梭、住在最好的街区，或者去最好的医院、学校和工作岗位。这是达尚·马德利，他是一名南非记者。而黑人则住在拥挤的郊区，那里距离你在城里想要的几乎所有东西都非常o远。这个国家统治阶级的白人少数派将这种制度称为阿帕尔特，直译过来
to separateness. Our policy is one which is called by an African's word apartheid. And I'm afraid that has been misunderstood so often. It could just as easily and perhaps much better be described as a policy of good-nableness. of good neighbourliness. A partate leaders like Hendrick for Foot claimed that segregated cities were better for everyone. And a partate was strictly enforced. Police would patrol neighborhoods to make sure that white people and black people weren't living together. If you lived in a house, they'd come knocking on your door. But the apartheid system was never airtight and people found creative ways to slip through
就是隔离。我们的政策被称为南非语中的“种族隔离”（apartheid）。恐怕这个词经常被误解。它同样可以、甚至更好地被描述为一种“睦邻友好”政策。“睦邻友好”。阿帕尔特的领导人，如亨德里克·维沃尔德（Hendrik Verwoerd）声称，隔离的城市对每个人都更好。而且种族隔离得到了严格执行。警察会在街区巡逻，确保白人和黑人没有住在一起。如果你住在一栋房子里，他们就会来敲你的门。但种族隔离制度从来都不是天衣无缝的，人们找到了巧妙的方法来钻
the cracks. If you lived in a high-rise building with 500, 600 flats in it, you know, they weren't going to go through each and every flat to come and look for any illegal persons. You could easily disappear into flatland. In over the years many families like Louise disappeared into one high-rise apartment building in particular, a tower called Ponty City. I don't think there's anybody in Johannesburg that doesn't know Ponty might not have been there but everybody knows Poni. Even looking at Joburg's Skyline now, Punti's hard to miss.
空子。如果你住在一栋有500、600套公寓的高层建筑里，你知道的，他们不可能逐个房间去搜查非法滞留人员。你很容易就能在公寓大厦里隐匿起来。多年来，许多像路易斯这样的家庭都隐匿在某一栋特定的高层公寓楼里，那是一座名叫庞蒂城的塔楼。我想约翰内斯堡没有人不知道庞蒂的，可能没去过，但人人都知道庞蒂。即使现在看约堡的天际线，庞蒂也很难被忽视。
First of all, it's 54 stories tall. That makes it the tallest apartment building on the entire African continent. And it certainly makes a taller than any of the other buildings around it. It's also completely circular. If you were to look at Punti from above, you'd see that the center's just this open hollow
首先，它有54层高。这使得它成为整个非洲大陆最高的公寓楼。它当然也比周围任何其他建筑都要高。它还是完全圆形的。如果你从上方俯瞰庞蒂，你会发现中心是一个开放的空心
core designed to allow natural ventilation and to let in daylight. The building looks kind of like a massive concrete toilet roll. It's also got this glowing red billboard for a cell phone company wrapping around the top like a crown. So wherever you are in the city, you can easily spawn it. Punti's larger than life architecture also comes with the larger than life reputation. a crown, so wherever you are in the city, you can easily spawn it. Pontis larger than life architecture also comes with the larger than life reputation. For many, the building symbolizes Johannesburg, because over the past four decades, its fortunes have basically mirrored the cities. Because of its scale, because of its size, its chick at history, its toughness, its roughness, talks to the
核心，旨在实现自然通风并引入日光。这栋建筑看起来有点像一个巨大的混凝土卫生纸卷。它的顶部还缠绕着一个发光的手机公司红色巨型广告牌，就像一顶王冠。所以无论你在城市的哪个地方，你都能一眼认出它。庞蒂超越现实的建筑风格也伴随着超越现实的名声。像一顶王冠，所以无论你在城市的哪个地方，你都能一眼认出它。庞蒂超越现实的建筑风格也伴随着超越现实的名声。对许多人来说，这座建筑象征着约翰内斯堡，因为在过去四十年里，它的命运基本上可以说是这座城市的缩影。因为它的规模，因为它的大小，它那不同寻常的历史、它的坚韧、它的粗犷，都在诉说着
Jobo condition. That's Melinda Silverman, an architectural historian who studies inner-city Johannesburg. It has spoken to a city which goes very rapidly through cycles of decline and prosperity and decline and prosperity and decline and prosperity. Ponti has always been kind of a vertical waiting room for admission to South African society, but it's also been a laboratory, a place where the city seems to try out new versions of itself. Years before Ponti became a hideaway for interracial families like Louise, it attracted a much different clientele and to understand who first lived there and why. We have to go back to the 1960s before Ponte was even built. At the start of the
约堡的现状。说话的是梅琳达·西尔弗曼，一位研究约翰内斯堡市中心的建筑历史学家。它展现了一座经历着极快衰落与繁荣、衰落与繁荣、衰落与繁荣周期的城市。庞蒂一直某种程度上是通往南非社会准入的垂直候诊室，但它也是一个实验室，一个这座城市似乎在尝试自我全新版本的地方。在庞蒂成为像路易斯这样的跨种族家庭的避风港的几年前，它吸引了截然不同的客群，而要了解谁最初住在那里以及原因，我们得回到20世纪60年代，在庞蒂建造之前。在60
60s, the apartheid system had been firmly in place for more than 10 years and South Africa's economy was a rising star in the world. It had just given birth to a new currency, the Rand, which was already stronger than the US dollar. The country's success was largely driven by its access to cheap black labour and its rich gold deposits. We were the major gold producers in the world and the feeling was that if we could continue being the major gold producers and keep an increasingly raced of black population under control, the future was brilliant. Unless of course you were black.
年代初，种族隔离制度已经牢固确立了十多年，南非的经济是世界上的新星。它刚刚诞生了一种新货币——兰特，当时已经比美元还要强势。这个国家成功很大程度上得益于其廉贵的黑人劳动力和丰富的黄金储量。我们是世界主要的黄金生产商，当时的共识是，如果我们能继续作为主要黄金生产商，并把日益受到种族限制的黑人人口控制住，未来将是一片光明。当然，除非你是黑人。
Over the next decade foreign investment in South Africa doubled, but skilled workers were in short supply. Because the government had denied the majority of the population a decent education, it had to full the gap by recruiting single white men from all over Europe. The country's white population increased by over 50 percent between 1963 and 1972. These newcomers saw a strong economy and an idyllic life for white people. Whereas if you were a middle class person living inside Africa, you probably had at least two people doing that stuff for you. And there was one square mile of Inner City Joberg, the future site of Ponte Tower,
在接下来十年里，外国对南非的投资翻了一番，但熟练工人严重短缺。由于政府剥夺了绝大多数人口接受良好教育的权利，它不得不通过从欧洲各地招募单身白人来填补这个缺口。在1963年至1972年间，该国的白人人口增加了50%以上。这些新来者看到了强劲的经济和白人理想的生活。相比之下，如果你是南非的中产阶级人士，你家里可能至少有两个人为你做这些琐事。而在约堡市中心有一平方英里的地方，也就是庞蒂大厦未来的所在地，
there was a regular landing place for these European migrants in the 1960s and 70s. It was home to the city's most famous bars and live music joints. A place where specialty stores sold French magazines, Italian shoes and American rock and roll, it had a shiny, vibrant, bohemian edge that people compared to New York's Greenwich Village or Blendon's Soho District. But it was also a place that felt almost like it wasn't in South Africa at all. Like most of Joe Berg's nicest neighborhoods, this area was zoned exclusively for white people.
这里是20世纪60、70年代这些欧洲移民的常规落脚点。这里有全市最著名的酒吧和现场音乐场所。专卖店里出售法国杂志、意大利鞋履和美国摇滚乐，这里有一种光鲜、充满活力、放荡不羁的边缘感，人们将其与纽约的格林威治村或伦敦的苏荷区相提并论。但这里也让人感觉仿佛根本不在南非境内。就像约堡绝大多数最好的街区一样，这个区域是专门划给白人专属居住的。
Black South Africans could work there, but unless they were living servants, they had to be out by nightfall each evening. Developers could hardly satisfy the demand for high rise apartments in this part of the city. Buildings kept getting bigger and taller, but that wasn't the only thing fueling the development of Joe Biggs new high-rises. The other sort of driver, I would say, was ideological, and it was the extraordinary sense of white confidence that this was a great economy, these were good times. This was why people wanted to make
南非黑人可以在那里工作，但除非他们是住家仆人，否则每天日落前必须离开。开发商几乎无法满足该市对高层公寓的需求。建筑越建越大、越建越高，但这并不是推动约堡新建高层建筑的唯一因素。我可以说，另一种驱动力是意识形态上的，那是一种非凡的白人自信心，认为这是一个伟大的经济体，这是好时光。这就是为什么人们想要在风景中
them more on the landscape. South Africa has a modern progressive, impressive place. Of course, South Africa was neither truly modern nor progressive at this time. This was the era of African independence. Across the continent, old colonies were falling like dominoes, and by the mid-1960s, most African countries were black-roared. This decade is the decade of African independence. The people of Ghana see their freedom as more than a local tribe. For they are now the only all-African dominion in the British Commonwealth. In the new Africa, one more independent country, the state of Uganda.
留下更多痕迹。南非是一个现代化、进步、令人印象深刻的地方。当然，当时的南非既不真正现代，也不真正进步。这是非洲独立的时代。整个非洲大陆上，旧殖民地如多米诺骨牌般倒塌，到20世纪60年代中期，大多数非洲国家都由黑人统治。这个十年是非洲独立十年。加纳人民将他们的自由视为不仅仅是一个地方部落的事。因为他们现在是英联邦内唯一的全非自治领。在新非洲，又多了一个独立国家，乌干达国。
To much of the world, South Africa's white government was starting to look pretty backwards, and it didn't help that the country had recently thrown several of the anti-apartheid movements most powerful leaders in jail for life, including a young lawyer named Nelson Mandela. But Jobberg's new buildings kept getting bigger and more audacious, almost as if the government was trying to prove its worldliness. By the early 1970s, huge skyscrapers were sprouting up across central Joburg, including Ponte. Ponte starts off being a tower, a round tower.
对世界上许多人来说，南非的白人政府开始显得相当落后，而且该国最近将反种族隔离运动的几位最有权势的领导人判处终身监禁，其中包括年轻的律师纳尔逊·曼德拉，这毫无帮助。但约堡的新建筑越来越大、越来越大胆，仿佛政府在试图证明它的世界性。到20世纪70年代初，巨大的摩天大楼在约堡市中心拔地而起，其中包括庞蒂。庞蒂最初是一座塔楼，一座圆形的塔楼。
That's architect Rodney Crosscoff, who was one of the three architects who designed the building. So now I imagine again, there's tall tower, 54 stories tall, with a hole down the middle. And the whole outside of it, it is made out of raw concrete, unpainted, unpolished, and then at its foot, it's really anchored, it's so beautifully done. People, once upon a time, said it looks a bit like a wedding cake. But not everyone agreed the building was beautiful. Some thought it looked like an ugly, brutalist wedding cake.
这是建筑师罗德尼·克罗斯科夫（Rodney Crosscoff），他是设计这座建筑的三位建筑师之一。所以现在再次想象一下，那座高塔，54层高，中间有一个洞。而它的整个外表，都是用毛坯混凝土做成的，没有油漆，没有打磨，然后它的底部真正扎根，做得太漂亮了。曾经有人说它看起来有点像结婚蛋糕。但并不是所有人都认为这座建筑很美丽。有些人觉得它看起来像个丑陋、野兽派的结婚蛋糕。
Straight after it was built, it was voted as the second ugliest building in Johannesburg. Not even the honor of being the first ugliest. The second ugliest. When can even the second ugliest? Second ugliest or not, Ponti Tower was popular. Residents started moving in even before the building was finished, lured by its furnished flats and panoramic city views. All the units in Ponti faced both inward and outward,
它刚建成后不久，就被评为约翰内斯堡第二丑的建筑。甚至连成为第一丑的荣誉都没有。第二丑的。怎么连第二丑的都算？不管是不是第二丑，庞蒂大厦很受欢迎。甚至在建筑完工之前，居民们就开始搬进去了，被其带家具的公寓和全景城市景观所吸引。庞蒂的所有单元都朝内和朝外，
with entrances wrapping around the central core. From one side of the building, you could see the entire downtown skyline. From another, you could catch entire Red Bee matches at the city's main stadium. By the time Ponti was completed in 1975, From another, you could catch entire rugby matches at the city's main stadium. By the time Ponte was completed in 1975, its 470 flats were in high demand. There were all sorts of analogies about how it was going to use as much electricity as average small town and it would have more people than every small town in South Africa. The developers saw it that way too.
入口环绕着中央核心。从建筑的一侧，你可以看到整个市中心的天际线。从另一侧，你可以赶上城市主体育场的整场橄榄球比赛。到1975年庞蒂完工时，从另一侧，你可以赶上城市主体育场的整场橄榄球比赛。到1975年庞蒂完工时，其470套公寓需求量极高。有各种各样的比喻说它将消耗相当于普通小镇那么多的电力，它的人口将超过南非的每一个小镇。开发商也是这么看的。
On Pontys' ground floor, they built an elaborate shopping mall and skimmed about putting a miniature ski slope in the open core. So we had restaurants, butchabaka, candlestick maker designed in that space. And we really did see it as a little city. But even as Pontys' new residents were moving in, the city around them was cracking apart. At this time, Johannesburg's inner city was almost exclusively white.
在庞蒂的底楼，他们建造了一个精致的购物中心，并考虑在开放的核心中设置一个微型滑雪道。所以在那个空间里我们有餐馆、肉铺、烛台制造商。我们确实把它看作是一个小城市。但就在庞蒂的新居民搬进来的时候，他们周围的城市正在崩裂。当时，约翰内斯堡的市中心几乎完全是白人。
Black South Africans lived on the edges of the city and communities called townships. In 12 miles, Southwest of Ponty, in a black township called Soweto, a new revolt against apartheid had begun. What began as a black protest against being taught in Soweto, a new revolt against apartheid had begun. What began as a black protest against being taught in Africa, a language they regard as useless and back of their masters, is now a command of the station of urban black frustration.
南非黑人住在城市边缘被称为“乡镇”（townships）的社区里。在庞蒂西南12英里处，在一个名为索韦托的黑人乡镇，一场反抗种族隔离的新起义已经爆发。最初是为了抗议在索韦托被教授……一场反抗种族隔离的新起义已经爆发。最初是因为黑人抗议被灌输南非语——他们认为这种语言毫无用处，是主人的语言——现在这已经成为城市黑人挫败感的集结号。
Protests escalated, and on June 16, 1976, police killed at least 176 high school students during a peaceful protest march. Images of the massacre quickly circled the globe, inspiring renewed calls to end white rule. As a Paul of smoke rises over this black community, so rises African anticipation. Throughout South Africa, they see minority white regimes falling or coming under greater pressure.
抗议活动升级，1976年6月16日，警察在一次和平抗议游行中杀害了至少176名中学生。大屠杀的画面迅速传遍全球，激发了结束白人统治的又一轮呼吁。当一缕烟雾在这片黑人社区上空升起时，非洲人的期待也随之升起。在整个南非，他们看到少数白人政权正在倒台或面临更大的压力。
The Soweto uprising also sent Joe Bugs urban planning dreams crashing. The June 16th uprising and the international sanctions and boycotts that followed helped destroy the country's economy. It became difficult to keep all the newly constructed high rises fully occupied. And it wasn't just the crashing economy. Like many cities around the world, Johannesburg had started to experience a wave of suburbanization with white people moving out of the inner city and into new suburbs. Meanwhile, many Black South Africans were fleeing from the poverty and violence of the townships.
索韦托起义也让约堡的城市规划梦想破灭。6月16日的起义以及随之而来的国际制裁和抵制帮助摧毁了该国的经济。要让所有新建的高层建筑保持满租变得很困难。不仅仅是崩溃的经济。就像世界上许多城市一样，约翰内斯堡开始经历一波郊区化浪潮，白人纷纷搬出市中心，搬进新的郊区。与此同时，许多南非黑人正逃离乡镇的贫困和暴力。
For them, the inner city was an alluring option, especially Ponte. If it were all flats, there would have been more affordable, really good location, the ability to be really near to the workplaces that still existed in the inner city. In the 1980s, it was still illegal for black, Indian and colored South Africans to live in these areas, but the scale and density of the inner city made the laws harder to enforce. I think the anonymity that really had density living offered, which meant that people
对他们来说，市中心是一个诱人的选择，尤其是庞蒂。如果全是公寓，就会更实惠、地理位置非常好，能够非常靠近市中心依然存在的那些工作场所。在20世纪80年代，黑人、印度人和有色人种南非人住在这些地区仍然是违法的，但市中心的规模和密度使得这些法律更难以执行。我认为密集居住带来的匿名性，意味着人们
could have been less conspicuous if they were legal. There was an Italian gentleman who had a black lady as a wife. There's a French gentleman who also had a coloured wife. That's Louis Smetzigan, whose parents were in an illegal interracial marriage. He's talking about some of the other families who also lived in Ponte in the early 1980s. As the lines between black and white began to blur in buildings like Ponte, so the Africans coined a new term for the phenomenon.
如果他们不合规范，就不会那么显眼。有一位意大利绅士，他的妻子是一位黑人女性。还有一位法国绅士，他也有一位有色人种妻子。那是路易斯·斯穆茨，他的父母进行了非法的跨种族婚姻。他正在谈论20世纪80年代初也住在庞蒂的其他一些家庭。随着庞蒂这样的建筑中黑人和白人之间的界限开始模糊，南非人创造了一个新词来形容这种现象。
They called it graying. For Louis, gray areas were in escape. Ponte was a place where his family could be together, freely without fear of arrest or public scrutiny. I don't even remember seeing any building raids or anything like that. You almost had a protection being in the flatland, you know, because there were so many places going to a flat here, going to a flat there, you know,
他们称之为“灰化”（graying）。对路易斯来说，灰色地带是一种逃离。庞蒂是一个他的家人可以聚在一起，自由自在、不用担心被捕或公众审视的地方。我不记得看到过任何建筑突击搜查之类的事情。你住在公寓大厦里几乎有一种保护，你知道的，因为这里有太多地方，去这套公寓，去那套公寓，你知道的，
they weren't going to close down a whole block of flats at once. But that didn't mean that there weren't stresses associated with life in Ponty. Police regularly set up checkpoints to monitor who came in and out of black and white areas of the city. When Louise family went through these checkpoints, his mother would sit in the back seat, posing as the family's maid. She'd have to sit in the back. It was plain as simple as that she sat in the back. Black and coloured people who were legally settled in the inner city
他们不可能一下子封锁掉一整栋公寓楼。但这并不意味着与庞蒂生活相关的没有压力。警察定期设立检查站，监控谁进出城市的黑人区和白人区。当路易斯一家穿过这些检查站时，他的母亲会坐在后座上，假装是家里的女佣。她必须坐在后座。事情就是这么简单直接，她坐在后座。合法定居在市中心的黑人和有色人种
also struck a hard bargain. Landlords would turn a blind eye to the colour of the resident's skin and residents would have to turn a blind eye to rising rents and poor maintenance. Their status of illegality, I think, was absolutely critical to the decline because the minute you are an illegal tenet you have no protection of the law. So rents can be ramped up. Then if rents are ramped up, how do you afford the rent?
也做出了艰难的妥协。房东对居民的肤色睁一只眼闭一只眼，而居民则必须对不断上涨的租金和糟糕的维护睁一只眼闭一只眼。我认为，他们的非法身份对衰落绝对至关重要，因为一旦你成为非法租户，你就没有任何法律保护。所以租金可以被抬高。然后如果租金被抬高，你如何承担租金？
You sublet. And then the rents go up even further and then you sublet even more. Inside Ponte, apartments started to get crowded and grimy. Plumbing broke down. Trash began to fill the open core in the center of the building like an oversized concrete garbage can. There were giant piles of old mattresses, furniture, and rubble.
你转租。然后租金进一步上涨，然后你转租更多。在庞蒂内部，公寓开始变得拥挤和肮脏。水管坏了。垃圾开始像一个超大的混凝土垃圾桶一样填满建筑中心的开放核心。那里堆着巨大的旧床垫、家具和瓦砾。
The eventually legend spread that the trash had piled up so high it reads the 14th story of the building. Pretty soon, banks stopped issuing home loans in the area and white people kept moving out. By the late 1980s, what you thought of Ponte and the surrounding neighbourhood called Hilbrough probably depended a lot on the colour of your skin. What's a bourbon arts would have been terrifying to go into Hilbrough and Hilbrough would have been a place of fear and blunt and darkness whereas I think for people in the townships that is mostly black and
最终有传言说，垃圾堆得太高，甚至堆到了建筑的14层。很快，银行停止在该地区发放房屋贷款，白人不断搬走。到20世纪80年代末，你对庞蒂及周边名为希尔布罗（Hillbrough）街区的看法，可能很大程度上取决于你的肤色。对郊区居民来说，进入希尔布罗会是极其可怕的，希尔布罗会是一个充满恐惧、麻木和黑暗的地方，然而我认为对于乡镇居民来说，也就是大多数黑人和
coloured people. Hillbrough would have been this great be kind of opportunity your way into the city your way of experiencing urban life. And all these changes in the inner city were foreshadowing a much bigger change that was about to happen to all of South Africa. On February 2, 1990, then President F.W. Declarek went in front of Parliament to give his annual state of the nation's speech. Today, I'm able to announce far-reaching decisions. For three decades, the apartheid government had banned many anti-apartheid political parties. They arrested their members and sometimes forced them into exile.
有色人种。希尔布罗将是一种巨大的机遇，是你进入城市、体验都市生活的方式。市中心的所有这些变故，都在预示着整个南非即将发生一个更大的巨变。1990年2月2日，当时的总统F.W.德克拉克（F.W. de Klerk）在议会发表年度国情咨文。今天，我能够宣布具有深远意义的决定。三十年来，种族隔离政府取缔了许多反种族隔离政党。他们逮捕了成员，有时甚至迫使他们流亡。
No one was expecting the President to announce the end of that practice. He shocked nearly everyone watching. The first vision of the African National Congress, the Pan-Africanist Congress, the South African Communist Party, is being resumbed. The government has taken a firm decision to release Mr. Mandela unconditional. This speech would change the course of South African history. A week later, after 27 years in prison for treason, Nelson Mandela was free. And after decades of struggle, the end of apartheid was suddenly imminent.
没有人预料到总统会宣布结束这种做法。他的话震惊了几乎所有观看直播的人。非洲国民大会、泛非主义者大会、南非共产党的禁令正在解除。政府已做出坚决决定，无条件释放曼德拉先生。这次演讲将改变南非历史的进程。一周后，在因叛国罪入狱27年后，纳尔逊·曼德拉重获自由。经过几十年的斗争，种族隔离的结束突然间迫在眉睫。
From all over the world, exiled political activists began to return. They wanted to help shape a dramatically changing country. I think it was 1991, the year that we came back in. That's Lensware Mojatle, an anti-apartheid activist who fled South Africa in 1981. Like many other returning exiles, Lensware took advantage of the centrality and cheap rent of the inner city and moved into a friend's 24th floor apartment in Ponti Tower. Ponti and the surrounding neighborhood were still ran down, but Lensware was surprised to find the area felt a lot like the Western cities where he'd spent the past decade.
来自世界各地的流亡政治活动家开始归来。他们想要帮助塑造一个发生剧烈变化的国家。我想那是1991年，我们回国的年份。说话的是伦斯沃·莫贾特勒（Lensware Mojatle），一位在1981年逃离南非的反种族隔离活动家。像许多其他回国流亡者一样，伦斯沃利用了市中心的中心位置和低廉租金，搬进了朋友在庞蒂大厦24楼的公寓。庞蒂和周边街区仍然很破旧，但伦斯沃惊奇地发现，这个地区感觉很像他过去十年度过的西方城市。
That's where the music was happening. 24 hour food outlets that were not seen anywhere else were there. So the lights were on throughout. Yeah, it was like being in New York. Some of the old European cafes from the 50s and 60s were still standing, serving late night espresso's and thick schnitzels. But alongside them were new shops and nightclubs, including one run by the famous South African trumpeter, Hugh Masakela, who had recently returned from his own exile. So if you wanted to find anybody who were around you, we never used to sleep. Instead, Mochatlis is the state of all night, talking about the future of their new
那是音乐发生的地方。随处可见全天候营业的餐饮店，这是其他地方看不到的。所以灯光彻夜通明。是的，就像置身于纽约一样。50和60年代的一些老欧洲咖啡馆仍然屹立不倒，供应深夜意式浓缩咖啡和厚实的炸肉排。但与它们并存的是新开的商店和夜总会，其中包括由著名的南非小号手休·马萨克拉（Hugh Masekela）经营的一家，他最近也从自己的流亡生涯中归来。所以如果你想找到身边的任何人，我们从不睡觉。相反，莫贾特勒说他们整夜不睡，伴着啤酒和白兰地畅谈他们新国家的未来。
country over beers and brandy's. Tabor and Becky, who would later become president of South Africa, lived in the building next to Ponte. At the time of the first democratic election in 1994, one observer counted 50 of the new members of parliament, staying in Ponte and the surrounding area. But the end of apartheid didn't represent the end of Ponte Towers' evolution. The transition to black rule in South Africa also meant the end of the country's tightly closed borders, which for decades had cracked open only for white immigrants and a few laborers
塔博·姆贝基（Thabo Mbeki）后来成为了南非总统，他曾住在庞蒂隔壁的建筑里。在1994年第一次民主选举时，一位观察员统计有50名新议会成员住在庞蒂及周边地区。但种族隔离的结束并不意味着庞蒂大厦演变的终结。南非向黑人统治的过渡也意味着该国紧闭国门的结束，几十年来，这些大门仅对白人移民和来自周边国家的少数劳工敞开。
from the surrounding countries. Throughout the 1990s, immigrants began arriving in Johannesburg by the tens of thousands, and many of them landed in Ponte. I'm from Malawi. Do you know me? I'm from Zambia. That's footage from a film called Africa Shafed by Ingrid Martens. She filmed entirely inside of Ponte's elevators.
整个20世纪90年代，移民开始以数万人的规模涌入约翰内斯堡，其中许多人落脚在庞蒂。我来自马拉维。你认识我吗？我来自赞比亚。这是英格丽德·马滕斯（Ingrid Martens）一部名为《非洲之轴》（Africa Shafted）的电影素材。她完全是在庞蒂的电梯内部拍摄的。
That's why it sounds like there are doors opening and shutting in the background all the time. Martens found people from dozens of countries living in the building, mostly encrowded apartments shared by several families. Some had come for work. Others were fleeing political persecution, but they shared one important experience with past residents. For them, Ponte was a place you could start over. Over the years, Ponte, like South Africa itself, continued to have its ups and downs. By the late 90s, the building's physical decline made it a haven for criminals, who moved into the building and ran it like a vertical slum.
这就是为什么背景里听起来总有门在开开关关。马滕斯发现来自几十个国家的居民住在这栋建筑里，大多是几个家庭合住拥挤的公寓。有些人是为了工作而来。另一些人则是为了逃避政治迫害，但他们与过去的居民有着一个共同的重要经历。对他们来说，庞蒂是一个你可以重新开始的地方。多年来，庞蒂就像南非本身一样，继续起伏跌宕。到了90年代末，建筑的物理衰落使其成为罪犯的避风港，他们搬进大楼，像经营垂直贫民窟一样管理它。
But Ponte still remained a place of big ideas and wild experimentation. Developers made a few attempts to gentrify the tower and turn it into luxury apartments again. But ultimately, those plans didn't really work. Ponte today remains a lot like it was at the end of a part aid, a home for recently arrived immigrants from all over Africa. On a recent Saturday morning, a pair of kids are battling it out on a foosball table at the base of Ponte city. You can tell it's a close game. Oh, come on! Come on, come on! Just down the road, people are crowding around a wall
但庞蒂依然是一个充满宏大想法和疯狂实验的地方。开发商曾多次尝试将这座塔楼高档化，并将其重新变成豪华公寓。但最终，这些计划并没有真正奏效。今天的庞蒂在很大程度上仍然很像种族隔离结束时的样子，它是来自非洲各地的刚抵达移民的家园。最近的一个周六早晨，两个孩子正在庞蒂大厦底部的桌上足球台上激烈对决。你可以看出这是一场势均力敌的比赛。噢，拜托！来吧，来吧，来吧！顺着路往下走，人们正围着一面墙，
that's covered in hundreds of scribbled slips of paper in several different languages. Some are torn or stuck over older ones with wides of bubblegum. It's a sort of analog craigslist, a message board for newcomers searching for accommodation in Ponte and around Hillbrough. I'm looking for a lady or a guy to rent a bedroom or a balcony at 801 Metropolitan Tadop.
墙上贴着几百张用几种不同语言写着涂鸦的小纸条。有些被撕掉了，或者用大泡泡糖粘在旧纸条上面。这是一种类似模拟版的分类信息网站，是新来者寻找庞蒂和希尔布罗周边住宿的留言板。我在寻找一位女士或一位先生在801号大都会塔楼合租一间卧室或阳台。
And the list goes on. Sifting through the messages, the demand feels limitless. Like South Africa itself, Ponte has gone from a symbol of white opulence to something far more complicated. It's hopeful, and it's a little rough around the edges. It's a microcosm of the country's history, but it's also a place that moves on. And the strange concrete tube at the center of Joeburg
名单还在继续。仔细翻看这些留言，需求似乎是无限的。就像南非本身一样，庞蒂已经从白人富裕的象征变成了一个远为复杂的存在。它充满希望，边缘也带有一点粗粝。它是该国历史的一个缩影，但它也是一个向前迈进的地方。约堡天际线中心的那个奇怪的混凝土管道
Skyline continues to play the same role for newcomers that it always has. The diversity is the same. You know, there might have been chicks, leverkins, pochabies, Italians, and daines living in Hillbrough, then, but now the etc. etc. It always has been your entry point into the city. So did Ponty Tower seem vaguely familiar but you can't quite put your finger on it? It's because you probably saw it or a tower inspired by it in a movie. I have a little apple hog about Ponty's life on screen after this. Even though we only heard Dasha and Moodleys voice in this episode, it was reported by two people, actually.
继续为新来者扮演着它一直以来扮演的角色。多样性是一样的。你知道的，当时希尔布罗可能住着捷克人、勒维金人、波查比人、意大利人和丹麦人，但现在等等等等。它一直是你进入城市的入口点。那么，庞蒂大厦听起来是否有点熟悉，但你又说不上来为什么？那是因为你可能在电影中看过它或受其启发的塔楼。这之后我将简要聊聊庞蒂在银幕上的生活。尽管我们在这一集中只听到了达尚·马德利的声音，但实际上它是两个人报道的。
The second reporter is Ryan Brown, and she was a resident of Ponti Tower, and has done a lot of reporting on the place. And one of the things about Ponti, that is pretty interesting, is that even though you might not know its actual history or even know its name, you might feel like it's kind of familiar as a place. And the reason is is because it has been depicted in movies in different ways. And I asked Ryan to talk to me about that. Well, Ponte has actually made quite a number of cameos in film and other popular culture.
第二位记者是瑞安·布朗（Ryan Brown），她曾是庞蒂大厦的居民，并对这个地方做过大量报道。关于庞蒂，有一件非常有趣的事情是，即使你可能不知道它的真实历史，甚至不知道它的名字，你可能也会觉得它作为一个地方有种熟悉感。原因在于它在电影中以不同的方式被描绘过。我请瑞安跟我聊聊这个。嗯，庞蒂实际上在电影和其他流行文化中客串过相当多次。
Most recently in the last resident evil film as a site of the zombie apocalypse. It was in District nine a few years ago and the robot becoming human story chappy a couple of years ago too. And it's made a cameo in a number of other films too. Interestingly, not always films that are set in Johannesburg, but always films that are set in places where there's something either kind of apocalyptic or just, you know,
最近一次是在上一部《生化危机》电影中，作为僵尸末日的发生地。几年前它出现在《第九区》中，几年前还有机器人获得人性的故事《超能查派》。它也在许多其他电影中客串过。有趣的是，并非总是以约翰内斯堡为背景的电影，但总是那些背景设定在某种带有末日色彩，或者仅仅是
sort of gritty and messy going on. Right. It has that vibe. It's not necessarily a Johannesburg vibe. It's the vibe of apocalypse that it gives off. Yeah, totally. But, you know, you have to sort of wonder where did filmmakers get the idea that Ponte would be the scene for the apocalypse? And I think it's rooted in the kind of stereotypes that people have about the inner city of Johannesburg, which are then in turn rooted in, I think, the fears that a lot of South Africans have about the city and what it's become since the end of apartheid.
那种残酷和混乱正在发生的地方的电影。没错。它有那种氛围。这不一定非得是约翰内斯堡的氛围。它散发的是一种末日的氛围。是的，完全如此。但是，你知道，你不得不怀疑电影制片人是从哪里得到这个想法的，即庞蒂会成为末日场景？我认为这根植于人们对约翰内斯堡市中心的种种刻板印象，而这些印象反过来又根植于，我认为，许多南非人对这座城市以及自种族隔离结束以来它变成什么样子的恐惧。
And there's also a number of films where it's not necessarily, Ponty, or it's not necessarily Johannesburg, but there's this, the idea of a tower that's a city in of itself that is its own sort of dark place, dread, for example, reminds me of the way that people talk about Ponty City as well. Yeah, exactly. And an interesting thing about dread is that the movie itself was filmed in Johannesburg
还有许多电影中，它不一定是庞蒂，或者不一定是约翰内斯堡，但存在这样一种概念：一座自成一体的城市塔楼，它本身就是一个黑暗的地方，比如《新特警判官》（Dredd），就让我想起人们谈论庞蒂城的方式。是的，完全正确。关于《新特警判官》的一个有趣之处在于，电影本身是在约翰内斯堡拍摄的，
and they didn't use Ponty as a set, but then there's a sort of massive apartment tower in the film, a 200 story building that has a hollow open core. So you have to wonder where they got that idea. Right. Why do you think it's so evocative and why do you think it's used in this way? Are you troubled by it in any way or are you kind of pleased when you see it depicted? I think the way it's come to be is a combination of two things. And the one is that Ponte has become this sort of metaphor for Johannesburg
他们没有用庞蒂作为布景，但电影中确实有一种巨大的公寓楼，一座拥有开放核心的200层建筑。所以你不得不怀疑他们是从哪里得到这个主意。没错。你认为为什么它如此具有唤起力，为什么它会以这种方式被使用？你对它有什么困扰吗，或者当你看到它被描绘时你觉得有点高兴？我认为它现在的样子是两件事结合的结果。其一是庞蒂已经成为约翰内斯堡
and for South Africa and this kind of outsized thing on the skyline on which people can project their fears about the city and what it's becoming. And I think filmmakers have just picked up on that. And then the other thing is, the aesthetic of the building, it's just pretty wild. I mean, it's just the sort of 50 stories of raw, brutal, concrete. It's got these kind of exposed concrete ribs on the inside.
和南非的一种隐喻，是天际线上那种被过度夸大的存在，人们可以在其上投射他们对这座城市及其演变成什么样子的恐惧。我认为电影制片人只是捕捉到了这一点。另一件事是，这座建筑的美学，它实在是太狂野了。我的意思是，这只是50层未经修饰的、残酷的混凝土。它的内部有这种裸露的混凝土肋骨。
The core is just this crazy, rocky space. You stare up and there's like 50 stories of windows staring back down at you and this sort of shaft of light. It's almost otherworldly. So it has this very cinematic quality to it. But I do find the way it appears in popular culture troubling because I think it sort of freezes in time this very negative vision of Johannesburg and this vision of Ponti. And Ponti and Johannesburg both have changed and are changing, you know, sort of extraordinarily quickly, Ponte. And Ponte and Johannesburg both have changed and are changing, you know, sort of extraordinarily quickly,
核心只是一个疯狂的、岩石密布的空间。你向上凝视，就像有50层楼的窗户回望着你，还有这样一道光束。它几乎超乎寻常。所以它具有非常强烈的电影质感。但我确实觉得它在流行文化中出现的方式令人不安，因为我认为它把对约翰内斯堡非常消极的愿景和对庞蒂的这种愿景在时间中冻结了。而庞蒂和约翰内斯堡都发生过且正在发生极其迅速的变化，庞蒂和约翰内斯堡都发生过且正在发生极其迅速的变化，
I think, and maybe you could say that about any city, but I think Johannesburg is a particularly unsentimental kind of city, and it's because it was started as this sort of mining town. It's always been a place where people just came to make money, to get rich, to get ahead. People don't have this kind of sentimental attachment to home in Johannesburg.
我想，也许你可以对任何城市这么说，但我认为约翰内斯堡是一座特别冷酷无情的城市，这是因为它最初是作为这种采矿小镇建立起来的。这里一直是一个人们来赚钱、致富、出人头地的地方。在约翰内斯堡，人们对家没有这种感伤的依恋。
And so the city sort of moves on and forgets very quickly. But then when you have the arbiters of popular culture, when you have filmmakers come in and create this, or you know, sort of reinforce this vision of Joe Berg or of Panty as these really dangerous, gritty, crime-ridded spaces, it kind of freezes that image in people's minds, and that's sort of what they think the city is like,
所以这座城市会向前发展并且忘记得非常快。但当你有了流行文化的仲裁者，当你有了电影制片人进来创造这个，或者说巩固对约堡或庞蒂的这种愿景——将它们视为极其危险、粗犷、充斥犯罪的空间时，它就在人们的脑海中冻结了这种形象，而这正是他们认为这座城市现在的样子，
whether or not it still is. And you lived there for a time, right? I did. I lived there for about a year coinciding with the filming of the Resident Evil movie. So I was treated to a number of days of the zombie apocalypse, and literally zombies wandering through my building screaming,
不管它是否真的还是那样。你曾在那里住过一段时间，对吧？是的。我在那里住了一年左右，正好赶上《生化危机》电影的拍摄。所以我体验了好几天的僵尸末日，字面意义上的僵尸在我的大楼里游荡、尖叫，
which seemed a sort of logical end point the zombie apocalypse and literally zombies wandering through my building screaming, which seemed a sort of logical endpoint to this pontymetaphor. And what way? Well, if ponties sort of represents a sort of chaotic way that Johannesburg has evolved since the end of a partake and the disarray of the city in that period, I mean, what represents disarray more than a zombie apocalypse? 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Ryan Brown and Dosh and Moodley with Delaney Hall.
这似乎是这个庞蒂隐喻的一种符合逻辑的终点。僵尸在我的大楼里游荡、尖叫，这似乎是这个庞蒂隐喻的一种符合逻辑的终点。在什么方面？嗯，如果庞蒂某种程度上代表了约翰内斯堡自种族隔离结束以来演变出的那种混乱方式，以及那段时间这座城市的混乱状态，我的意思是，有什么比僵尸末日更能代表混乱呢？本周的《99%隐形》由瑞安·布朗（Ryan Brown）和达尚·马德利（Dosh and Moodley）与德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）共同制作。
Mix and Tech Production by Sharif Usif, Music by Sean Rial with an additional song by Jenny Conley-Dries-O's John Newfeld and Nate Query. Our senior producer is Katie Mingle. Kirk Colstead is the digital director, but we all add in our two cents, including Emmett Fitzgerald, Avery Trouffman, Taren Mazza and me, Roman Mars.
混音与技术制作由谢里夫·乌西夫（Sharif Usif）完成，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）创作，并带有珍妮·康利-德里斯-奥斯（Jenny Conley-Dries-O's）、约翰·纽费尔德（John Newfeld）和内特·奎里（Nate Query）的额外歌曲。我们的高级制作人是凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）。柯尔克·科尔斯特ッド（Kirk Colstead）是数字总监，但我们所有人都贡献了微薄之力，包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、埃弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffman）、塔伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。
Special thanks to Ingrid Martens, who allowed us to use audio from her film, Africa Shafted. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by the Night Foundation and coin carrying listeners, just like you.
特别感谢英格丽德·马滕斯（Ingrid Martens），她允许我们使用她电影《非洲之轴》中的音频。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心电台街制作。99%隐形是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇聚了播客界最好、最具创新性节目的联盟。我们得到了奈特基金会和像你一样的热心听众的支持。
You can find 99% of visible and joint discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI orc. Or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you want to read a cool article by Kurt about fictional megacities in science fiction, you have to go to our website. It's 99PI dot org. Radio tapio. From P. from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到《99%隐形》并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上 @ Roman Mars，也可以在 99PI orc 上 @本节目。还可以在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上找到我们。但如果你想阅读库尔特（Kurt）关于科幻小说中虚构特大城市的一篇酷炫文章，你必须访问我们的网站。网址是 99PI dot org。Radiotopia，来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。